the iraqi army is once again in charge
of sinjar
home to iraq's azidi religious minority
the district is one of several disputed
areas
claimed by both the central government
in baghdad and the semi-autonomous
kurdish region
it has changed hands five times since
2003.
as part of an agreement between the two
sides in october baghdad deployed its
army to take control
the security situation inside sinjar is
the responsibility of the police
and the iraqi army controls all the
suburbs districts and sub-districts
the security is stable inside sinjar
there is no flag
other than the iraqi flag hosted inside
the town all the positions are under the
control of the iraqi government
after the fall of the late former
president saddam hussein in 2003
kurdish peshmerga fighters controlled
sinjar while the iraqi army was deployed
further south
both abandoned their positions in 2014
when the islamic
state of iraq and the levant or isil
launched an offensive across northern
iraq
much of the city of sinjar was destroyed
during the conflict
there's a lack of trust among the yazidi
minority towards both the federal
government in baghdad
and the regional government in kurdistan
due to
decades of neglect and because those
forces
failed to protect them when isil swept
through sinjar
killing and abducting thousands moreover
they feel that they have not been
meaningfully included in the
negotiations
that determine the future governance of
their region
among those not consulted on the
agreement are you zd armed groups that
sprung up in 2014
to help survivors escape isil and who
fought to retake sinjar
this group called the sinjar resistance
units has now handed over several
checkpoints to the iraqi army
but their commander told al jazeera that
the fighters will remain in the
mountains
we want guarantees to keep the residents
of sinjar safe
we will not hand sinjar to a specific
political party and we will not allow
anyone to deal with sinjar in an
oppressive way
the sinjar resistance units are closely
affiliated with the outlawed kurdistan
workers party
while other armed groups operating in
the district are linked to iran
many people living in sinjar say they
are tired of living at the mercy of
competing political interests
and some welcome the presence of the
iraqi army
having the iraqi government here is
better for us there are many parties and
illegal armed factions here
if the iraqi government is here the
situation will be better
and the security will be better but
there are concerns that the parties to
the agreement will meddle in the
selection of the local government and
police force choosing people who serve
their interests
people of sinjar should themselves form
the local police
the name should be chosen by the people
of sinjar
years after being displaced by the
conflict with isil a third of sinjar's
inhabitants have returned
and are beginning to rebuild their homes
that means they'll be able to cast their
ballots in elections in sinjar next year
and have a chance to have their voices
heard and choose their own leaders
simona feltin al-jazeera sinjar